I would say the most important and
unique part of the human brain and brain
evolution is that we've created a pause
between sensing and responding and in
that pause which exists to more or less
success as we'll talk about there's the
ability to judge and to make decisions
and then to have goals that you carry
out it's what allowed us humans to build
the cultures and societies that we've
created to have language and art and
music and all of the technology that
surrounds us all of this is potential
because we basically unshackled the
chains that make most creatures slaves
to their environment and don't allow
them to break free in the way that we
have in addition to bottom up is
top-down which is this ability that I
said to have goals we're in a constant
sort of struggle I mean a more positive
way of thinking about it as an
integration between bottom-up and
top-down we do it constantly we're
constantly dealing with the environment
sort of imposing itself upon us and
demanding it us to do certain things and
then us making decisions either for or
against it and so this is another
ancient part of our brains that exists
we do not parallel process multiple
top-down goals at the same time we it's
just not how our brains work I think you
know clearly we wish they would and we
sometimes believe that we could make
them but for the most part these
attention directing networks the
top-down networks engage and then they
need to switch when you redirect your
attention to something else so when you
start fragmenting your attention because
you're switching those patches rapidly
what's happening there is that you are
just losing fidelity of the information
that was being retained and what we
always you know the term that we'll use
in our papers is that you suffer a cost
a switch cost with each one of these and
that cost is often represented as a
low slowing down of your abilities or
loss of accuracy so what we see when we
do our research is that if you look at
perceptual abilities decision-making
memory emotional regulation all of these
capacities are diminished in terms of
the level that they could reach when
they're fragmented we're talking about
our education system and our medical
system our mental health system these
should be the institutions that were
created to help us have healthier Minds
they're not doing their jobs so I
actually put a lot more negative
attention to those industries rather
than the tech industry I feel that our
education system has largely focused
still from its foundations in the
Industrial Revolution to transfer
information content maybe now in some
more evolved schools skill development
but not really building the underlying
information processing systems of the
brain cognition attention teachers don't
even know if you ask them about their
classrooms who has the best working
memory
who is the best sustained attention who
is the best emotional regulation is the
best compassion they don't know the
answers to any of these questions they
know the reading and math performance
and that is that is a tragedy in my mind
so a closed loop means that you could
create a piece of software that records
your performance ideally your physiology
would know you in a deeper way than
anything possibly could
looking at your emotional responses your
facial expressions your heart rate your
brain activity use that data to create a
perfectly tailored experience to
challenge you appropriately in just the
perfect way and to reward you in such a
manner that you're deeply engaged that
plasticity changes your brain and
improves your performance turning that
game into what we now call digital
medicine so the idea is that we can use
this closed-loop experience to improve
abilities of the mind to a level that we
could knob not achieve with any molecule
because we don't have the targeting or
the personalization I mean full sensory
stimulation
ideally olfactory
visual auditory tactile stimulation
where you have this very very complex
loop of all this data about you flowing
into a software system that knows how to
interpret that data not trivial and then
feedback an environment that is
constantly and dynamically adjusting to
you to create this state that allows you
to adjust all these complex aspects of
your thinking this is our AI vision as I
always say AI for H AI artificial
intelligence for human intelligence
that's where I think this type of these
types of algorithms should go
[Music]